12 دقيقه
ثماني دول من اوبك بلس تعلن عن سلسله
تخفيضات طوعيه في الانتاج
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في تغطيه خاصه
لقرارات خفض انتاج النفط التي اتخذت في
الساعات القليله الاخيره اذ قادت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا
للانتاج النفطي من دول من داخل اوبك
وخارجها باجمال مليون و660 الف برميل
يوميا بدءا من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه
العام الجاري وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء
احترازي لتحقيق الاستقرار والتوازن في
اسواق النفط وفي التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه
انتاجها من النفط ب 500 الف برميل يوميا
فيما ستخفض الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف
برميل يوميا والكويت ب 128 الف برميل
يوميا واعلنت الجزائر عن خفضا طوعيا ب 48
الف برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق بانه
سيخفض انتاجه
عشر الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت سلطنه عمان
خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا اضافه الى
الجابون بثمانيه الاف برميل يوميا وفي
موسكو اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
الكسندر نوفاك ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا
في انتاجها من النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل
يوميا والذي اعلن في مارس الماضي تمديده
حتى نهايه هذا العام من متوسط مستوى
الانتاج الروسي وفقا لتقييمات المصادر
الثانويه لشهر فبراير كما ايضا خفضت
كازاخستان انتاجها بنحو 78 الف برميل
يوميا ضمن مجموعه الدول السبع او الثماني
التي اعلنت عن التخفيضات التوعيه اذا
مشاهدينا في خلال 12 دقيقه فقط شاهدنا اع
منسقه عن تخفيضات طوعيه من ثماني دول جاءت
هذه التخفيضات باكثر من مليون ونصف
المليون برميل يوميا واضافه الى هذه
التخفيضات وفي ضوئها اعلنت موسكو عن تخفيض
او تمديد تخفيضها الذي كانت قد اعلنته في
فبراير والذي شهدناه على مدار شهر مارس
بان هذا التخفيض الواقع بخمس مئه الف
برميل يوميا سيمدد حتى نهايه العام
بالتالي اجمال التخفيضات من تسع دول
تقدر
بمليون وستمائه وستين الف برميل يوميا
طبعا تاتي مشاهدينا هذه التخفيضات في ظل
التذبذب الحاد التي شهدته ليس فقط اسعار
النفط خلال الاسابيع الماضيه ولكن معظم
الاسواق الماليه بما فيها الورقه الماليه
لسعر النفط حيث شاهدنا اسعار النفط تتذبذب
من مستويات الثمانين دولار لتنخفض في
منتصف مارس الى 70 دولار للبرميل بل
تكسرها ولو لدقائق معدوده في ظل المخاوف
من انتشار
العدوى الهروب من المصارف الذي شهدته بعض
البنوك الامريكيه انتشارها وايضا الى
المنظومه المصرفيه تضاف الها المخاوف التي
شهدناها
تتبلور حول كريدي سويس انهيار هذا البنك
ومن ثم قيام يو بي اس بشرائه هذه
الاضطرابات الماليه والمخاوف زادت
الضبابيه حول الافق الاقتصادي
وبالتالي زادت من التذبذبات في سعر النفط
وواجب
ومن واجب منظمه اوبك وتحالف اوبك بلس جعل
هذه التذبذبات اقل حجما لدعم استقرار سعر
النفط لمصلحه المنتجين ولمصلحه المستهلكين
معا في نفس الوقت طبعا اسعار النفط
مشاهدينا كانوا قد شهدت في ظل التذبذبات
العاليه شهدت ايضا انخفاضات على مدار
الاسابيع والاشهر القليله الماضيه هذا هو
اداء خام برنت خلال الربع الاول شاهدنا
انخفاضات عليه فقط السبعه في المئه مع
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار انه بالاسبوعين
الاخيرين في ظل طبعا بعض المبادرات التي
اتخذتها البنوك المركزيه وعلى راسها البنك
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي خفت وتيره المخاوف
حول انتقال العدوى في القطاع المصرفي بعض
الشيء وبالتالي في اخر اسبوعين من مارس
شهدنا بعض الصعود في اسعار النفط من
مستويات السبعين دولار للبرميل نحو
مستويات الثمانين دولار للبرميل ولكن هنا
لربما العبره بانه ما نشهده اليوم هو ليس
فقط هو ليس محاوله للتحكم في الاسعار
لدعمها صعودا بل هي محاوله لتقليص حتى
التذبذب والتقلب في اسعار
النفط خاصه في ظل ما نشهده من تخبط من
مدراء السياسه النقديه عالميا وعلى راسها
البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي هل يكافح
مستويات التضخم ويشدد المعروض النقدي ام
هل يدعم القطاع المصرفي ويحميه
انهيارات وافلاسات هذا التخبط على صعيد
السياسه النقديه انعكس سلبا على الاسواق
الماليه وانعكس سلبا ايضا على ضبابيه
الاوتلوك والمشهد الاقتصادي العالمي وباتا
من المهم جدا ان نشهد تحركا من قبل تحالف
اوبك بلس بقياده السعوديه لاعاده يعني مسك
زمام المبادره في السوق النفطيه
وخفض حده التقلبات السعريه فيها للمزيد
مشاهدينا حول قرارات الخفض التخفيضات
الطوعيه لانتاج النفط ينضم الينا مباشره
من الرياض الدكتور فهد بن جمعه الخبير
النفطي وينضم الينا ايضا من الظهران دكتور
يوسف الشمري رئيس التنفيذي لسي ماركتس
اهلا بضيفي الكريمين وابدا معك دكتور فهد
يعني
لا
الانتاج الصخري كتحدي انتاج النفط الصخري
الامريكي كان تحديا كبيرا لاسواق النفط
كوفيد وجائحه كورونا تحدي كان لربما
الاكبر لاسواق النفط الان التحديات التي
تشهدها الاسواق الماليه بسبب ما نشهده من
مخاوف حول القطاع المصرفي كل هذه التحديات
دائما ما قامت السعوديه واوبك بلس
بمواجهتها بشكل مباشر تقييمك للقرار الذي
صدر هذا اليوم وموعده
اولا مساء الخير عليك استاذ ناصر وعلى
ضيفك الكريم وعلى جميع المشاهدين اولا
الشين
بمنظمه ومجموعه الاوبك بلس وعلى قوه
تماسكها والتي عززت
اسواق النفط وحافظت على استقرارها هذا
الخط ياتي في اصعب الاوقات نحن لاحظنا ان
الاسعار استمرت بانخفاضها ودائما نقول ان
80 دولار هو خط احمر والان هي تحت وحده
دولار هناك مشاكل كبيره ازمات
كانت في البدايه العام كان سعر الفائده
ارتفاع سعر الفائده
يضغط على اسعار النفط ثم جاءت الازمه
الماليه مع بعض البنوك التي
انهارت او على وجه الاكلاس كل هذه ادت الى
ظهور على اسواق النفط وعلى اسعار النفط
ادت الى قوه البيع في العقود الاجله
وكلها قفضت اسعار النفط
وهزت استقراره ولم نعد نعرف هل السوق في
حاله باكورديشن او كنت تانجو لم نعد نعرف
ذلك بسبب الارتباك بسبب هذه الازمات
تثبت مره ثانيه على قوه تماسكها والتزامها
بالمحافظه على استقرار اسواق النفط وهذا
الاجراء ولاحظ ان الخفض سواء يبدا بعد شهر
تقريبا وهذا دليل واضح ان هناك رؤيه ان
خلال هذه الشهر خلال هذا الشهر سوف تحدث
متغيرات كثيره وهذا سوف يضبط
الخفض وما سوف تقوم به بلس مستقبلا لذا
هذا الاجراء جاء في وقته لاعاده التوازن
لاسواق النفط والمحافظه على الطاقه
الفائضه والمحافظه على
امتدادات الطاقه
دكتور يوسف يعني دكتور فهد جاء على ذكر
كلمتين اضطراب ارتباك وهو واضح يعني تحرك
السوق من الباكورديشن منحنى الاسعار
الاجله الى تقريبا الكونتانجو وخاصه على
المدى الاقصر من المنحنى طويل الاجل هذا
يوضح درجه الارتباك والاضطراب خاصه بانه
الافق
الابعد اقتصاديا يعتريه الان الكثير من
الغموض يعني لا عادت الاسواق تعرف ما اذا
الفيدرالي سيرفع نسب الفائده ويستمر في
رفعها ام انه سيبدا بتخفيضها لربما منتصف
هذا العام فبالتالي الى اي درجه تعتقد
بانه
توقيت تدخل اوبك بلس في هذا التوقيت
تحديدا كان يجب ان يكون في هذا التوقيت
لاعاده مسك زمان الامور واعاده توجيه
السوق واعطاء الجايدنس الذي يحتاجه
اهلا وسهلا اخي ناصر وسعيد في الحديث
معاكم مع اخي الدكتور فهد وجميع مشاهدي
العربيه في الحقيقه هو توقيت او القرار
اتخذ اليوم من بلس طبعا هو متوقع انه يعلن
عنه غدا في اجتماع اللجنه واقابيه هو قرار
خلينا نقول احتياطي او انه احترازي اتخذ
من
المجموعه ككل من دول التحالف واعتقد انه
سيعطي خلينا نقول اللي هو اجراءات
احترازيه يعني كان هنالك في مع بدايه
العام 2023 عن ازمه حاله عدم العقيده
ارتفعت مع
الهويه اللي هو البنوك الفدراليه خصوصا
الفدراري الامريكي في الاستماع في رافع
نسب الفائده اللي هو الاستهداف التضخم
يكون عند الاثنين بالمئه فهذه طبعا شفنا
ازمه البنوك اللي حصلت وفي حتى في لقاء مع
العربيه قبل اسبوعين كان هنالك في توقعات
مننا انه نتوقع انه قد يكون هنالك في
تخفيضات تتخذها المجموعه وهذا ما شاهدناه
لليوم فانا اعتقد ان هذه الاجراءات ستعطي
خلي اللي هو حمايه بانه هو خلينا نقول
الارضيه ان الاسعار ما يكون فيه نوعا ما
من الدعم بحيث انه
المتوقع انه
تستمر في اسعار الفائده يعني ما نتوقع انه
يخفضه من الان حتى يمكن العام 2020 فاعتقد
هذه التخفيضات اللي اتخذتها اليوم
المجموعه ستعطي نوع من الدعم بما يواجهه
اللي هي ازمه البنوك والازمه الاقتصاديه
الحاليه في كمان هنا مساله مهمه يعني انا
لاحظتها انه التخفيضات التوعيه بالعاده
كانت تتخذها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فهنا اعتقد ان في دور جدا مهم لعبته
المملكه ان جميع الدول
ساهمت في هذه التخفيضات من المملكه من
الامارات الكويت وايضا في الحقيقه دول من
خارج دول الخليج فاعتقد هذا جدا مهم لعبته
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انه يكون هنالك
في تخفيضات طوعيه اضافيه من جميع المنتجين
المهمين وهذا يدل ان ان التحالف ككل تحالف
متماسك وله رؤيه موحده ضمن على الازمه
التي يواجهها الاسوا هذه الحال في هذا
العام النقطه بالفعل ملفته دكتور يوسف وفي
هذه النقطه دكتور فهد يعني كنا قد شهدنا
ابان الجائحه اتخاذ عدد من الدول الخليج
تحديدا على عاتقها تخفيضات طوعيه شاهدناها
السعوديه الامارات الكويت استمرت لمده شهر
ومن ثم تحملتها السعوديه بمفردها في وقت
المنتصف عام 2020 لحوالي ثلاثه اشهر
تخفيضات بمليون برميل يوميا
ما اشار له دكتور يوسف الان بان هناك
مجموعه موسعه اكبر من التخفيضات التوعيه
نتحدثون عن ثماني دول يضاف اليها روسيا
بتمديد خفضها لاحقا حتى نهايه السنه
وايضا طريقه الاعلان يعني ثماني اعلانات
من ثماني دول صدرت خلال 12 دقيقه هذا يدل
على مستوى عالي من التنسيق بين الدول
تحالف اوبيك بلس
نعم هذا صحيح وهذا دليل واضح ان هناك هدف
محدد لدول الاوبك بلس وهي تسعى لتحقيق هذا
الهدف ما هو هو المحافظه على توازن اسواق
النفط بين العرض والطلب عند افضل الاسعار
ليس فقط للمنتجين وانما ايضا للمستهلكين
وعندما تدرك هذه الدول مصالحها وان
التنسيق والالتزام سواء كان طوعيا او او
بقرارات من
المنظمه
دليل واضح ان هناك تحمل مسؤوليه ليس فقط
لحفظ اسواق النفط من الارتباك وانما ايضا
المحافظه على امر الطاقه عندما تكون
الاسواق غير متوازنه وتنخفض الاسعار
باشكال يعني بشكل كبير كما حدث في
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
من عام 20 23
طبعا بالنسبه
للتخفيض الانتاج الروسي الذي كان قد اعلن
سابقا قبل هذا الاعلان من الدول الثمانيه
وهو خفض بخمس مئه الف برميل يوميا وكان قد
تركت مده هذا الخفض مفتوحه لم يعرف هل
يكون الخفض الروسي لمده شهر ام شهرين على
ضوء الاعلان من الدول الثمانيه تعلن روسيا
بان هذا الخفض سيستمر حتى نهايه عام 20 23
ولكن دكتور يوسف ملفت هنا بانه الاعلان من
الدول الثماني لم يشمل روسيا جاء الاعلان
الروسي
متاخرا بعض الشيء عن الاعلان من الدول
الثمانيه لكن متماشيا معه في نفس السياق
وفي نفس المده الزمنيه هل تعتقد بانه هذا
يرفع عن تحالف اوبيك بلس
اي عبء عن اتهامات بانه هذا القرار او هذا
الموقف قد يتخذ على انه موقف سياسي او يقف
الى جانب روسيا شبه الاتهامات التي كلت
لاوبك بلس في اجتماع اكتوبر الماضي عندما
خفضت الانتاج وتم اتهامها بان هذا موقف
سياسي الى جانب روسيا ليكتشف الجميع بانه
جاء الخفض لدعم اسعار النفط والتي بالفعل
انخفضت بعد هذا القرار على ايه حال
والله يا اخي ناصر هو دائما يعني مجموعه
منظمه
دائما يعني عرضه للالتهامات السياسيه عبر
تاريخها فانا لن استغرب اذا قيل ان هذا
لدعم روسيا او غير دعم روسيا في يعني اي
تصريحات تطلع من اي وسائل اعلاميه لكن
المجموعه اثبتت للجميع ان قراراتها فنيه
وانها فصلت السياسه عن جميع القراءات
القرارات الانتاج التي سواء بالتخفيض او
في الزياده او في ابقاء معدلات الانتاج
كما هي فانا اتصور انه الاعلان الروسي
يعني لحق الاول لانه تخفيضات طوعيه وليست
يعني تخفيضات يعني باسم يعني التحالف
كتحالف رسمي فروسيا في تصور من مصلحتها
لما يكون هنالك في التخفيضات فاعتقد لما
اعلنت كل دوله اعلى طبعا هذه تخفيضات
نوعيه معناتها انها قرار سيادي لكل دوله
فلما اعلنت اللي هي الثمانيه دول مبدئيا
اعتقد انه قد انه
او لاحظت انها ضمن كمصلحتها الوطنيه
طبعا بغض النظر عن ما تتاخذه باقي الاعضاء
فقررت انه هو زياده المده اللي هي
التخفيضات اللي اتخذتها ال500 الف بامير
حتى نهايه عشرين ثلاثه وعشرين لا ننسى ان
روسيا عليها السقف اللي هو السعر عند
الستين دولار من الدول 7
فلما يتخذ قرار مثل هذا نوعا ما يدعمها في
من ناحيه التخفيضات تتمكن من بيع نفطها
باسعار اعلى خصوصا ما يذهب للهند والصين
فانا اتصور انه هو في قديم نوعا ما في
المصلحه الوطنيه لكن القرارات فنيه لا
يشتري لها دخل باي من العوامل السياسيه
سواء فيما يحسن حاليا في شرق اوروبا من
الحرب والسير الاوكرانيه او ما شابه
اتصور هنا في مساله جدا مهمه انه الازمه
او التقلبات اللي شهدناها في الاسواق
خصوصا في مطلع العام 200 مثل العالم زي ما
شفنا في 2020 ببدايه ازمه كوفيد عندما
وجبت المملكه في اتخاذ اجراءات استباقيه
كان هنالك رفض من بعض الاعضاء خصوصا روسيا
فاثبتت للجميع انه كان هو القرار الصعب
فانا اعتقد انها في نوعا ما قد لا تكون
نفس الازمه اللي شتنها في 2020 لكن في
موقف اشبه مما شفناه سابقا
طبعا ايضا ملفت انه الدول التي اعلنت
الدول الثماني التي اعلنت عن تخفيضاتها هي
جميعها الدول حققت المستويات الانتاج
المستهدفه في التخفيضات السابقه
فبالتالي هذا يعطي للاعلان مصداقيه اكبر
لانه تفقد المصداقيه اذا قامت دول اخرى لم
تحقق اصلا التخفيضات المطلوبه منها
بالاعلان عن تخفيضات اضافيه فبالتالي حصر
هذا الاعلان بالتخفيضات الطوعيه فقط في
الدول التي حققت مستويات الانتاج الى اي
درجه تعتقد
دكتور يوسف بانه هذا يرفع من مصداقيه
الاعلانات التي سمعناها اليوم بالضبط
لاحظنا مثلا انجولا نيجيريا ما هي ضمن
الدول لان اصلا عندها نقص في الامدادات
يعني ما وفقت جميع اللي هي الالتزامات
اللي تعاهدت بانتاجها فجميع الدول اللي
اعلنت اليوم التخفيضات هي خلينا نقول
المنتجين الملتزمين اللي هم محققين حوالي
100% من اللي هو الامتثال في الامدادات
فاللي هم فعلا اتخذتها تكون فعلا حقيقيه
وهذه مساله جدا مهمه لانه مثلا اسفل
الاتفاق اللي شفناه في نهايه العام 2022
كان هو اتفاق بتخفيض مليونين برميل لكن
الاسواق احتسبت حوالي مليون برميل وايضا
ذكرها سمو وزير الطاقه انه سيكون هنالك
حوالي مليون ومئه الف مليون مئه الف حسب
التحقيقات الحقيقيه لكن الارقام اللي
شفناها اليوم تحقيقات جميعها ستذهب الى
الاسواق اللي هي مليون و60 الف برميل وهذا
السبب قد تكون الدول الباقيه ما اعلنت
تخفيضات طوعيه لانه هي اصلا عندها نقص في
الانتاج الدكتور فهد لربما انهي معك
بمساله انه من الجميل جدا ان نشهد بانه
بقياده السعوديه في اخر كم من اجتماع وكم
من قرار نشهد دائما عنصر المفاجاه في
السوق في محاوله دائما فيما يبدو وما يعني
توعد به وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد
العزيز سابقا بابقاء المضاربين على رؤوس
اصابع ارجلهم
متاهبين دائما لاي مفاجاه
لتثنيهم عن المضاربه في السوق وزياده
التقلبات السعريه طبعا لمصلحه ارباحهم
المتزايده فبالتالي الى اي درجه ترى عنصر
المفاجاه هنا عنصر مفيد لدعم استقرار
السوق
نعم كما قال وزير الطاقه الامير عبد
العزيز سلمان نعم عنصر المفاجاه في غايه
الاهميه وهذا لم ياتي من فراغ بل ياتي من
دراسه البيانات والتوقعات وما يجري في
اسواق النفط وبناء على ذلك تاتي هذه
القرارات الاستباقيه وتفاجئ الاسوار
وهذا يعني
المضاربين والذين يحاولون ان يزعزعون
اسواق النفط نحن هنا
سوف تراقب الاسواق وسوف تتخذ القرارات
التي تؤدي الى استقرار اسواق النفط وما
زالت هذه المجموعه متماسكه وملتزمه وما
حدث اليوم
يعطي او يرسل رساله الى جميع المتداولين
في اسواق النفط والى المنتجين الاخرين عند
الاوبك سوف تحافظ وسوف تلتزم
بقراراتها في المحافظه على استقرار اسواق
النفط ولن تتخلى عن هذا عن هذه السياسه
وانها مبنيه على الاسس الاقتصاديه وعلى
علاقه باي عوامل سياسيه وهذا ما تثبت لنا
يوم بعد يوم ولا شك ان قياده السعوديه
لاوبك بلاس هو دور لها دور فاعل في هذه
العمليه التنسيق والتوافق بين هذه الدول
ودائما يلاحظ كما حدث في عشرين عشرين ان
السعوديه دائما
تتطوع بملايين البراميل اكثر من غيرها
وذلك دعم وتعزيز في التنسيق والتوافق بين
هذه الدول شكرا جزيلا لضيفي الكريمين من
الرياض دكتور فهد بن جمعه الخبير النفطي
ومن الظهران الدكتور يوسف الشمري رئيس
تنفيذي لسماركس شكرا لكما
اذا مشاهدينا بهذا ننهي هذه التغطيه
الخاصه للقرارات غير المسبوقه ثماني دول
في 12 دقيقه تعلن عن تخفيضات في انتاجها
طبعا تخفيضات طوعيه تصل تضاف لها التمديد
التخفيض الانتاج الروسي ليصبح حجم الانتاج
المخفض مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام الجاني